I do want to quickly follow up on the
Donald Trump soliciting sex for $10,000
from adult film star Jessica Drake prior
defenses from Donald trunk Trump to
sexual assault allegations have included
look at her almost as if a one woman
wasn't attractive enough for Trump to
sexually assault with Miss Utah the
former Miss Utah it was I've never met
this woman don't know who she is only
months after having a very specific and
detailed recollection about his
interactions with the former Miss Utah
and my analysis has always been if when
you're accused of sexual assault you
immediately go to reasons why the
specific accuser is unlikely to have
been victimized by you as opposed to
saying I don't sexually assault women
it's not a particularly good defense and
now Donald Trump has come out and
defended himself from these allegations
of propositioning Jessica Drake for
$10,000 and use of his private jet in
exchange for sex by saying I'm sure
she's been grabbed before because one of
her other claims was when she showed up
at Trump's hotel room years ago Trump
forcibly grabbed her and kissed her on
the lips even though that's not at all
what she wanted and here is Donald
Trump's latest defense if you can call
it that okay so I have a question for
you mr. Donald Trump on New Hampshire
today you are in Gettysburg Pennsylvania
over the weekend talking about a
contract with voters first hundred days
and yet some people say you defend
yourself too much on some of these
accusations versus just forging ahead
you get deed you feel sometimes it you
spent too much time doing that or do you
feel you have to do it in one way I
agree with them but in another way you
know these are stories that are made up
this is total fiction you'll find out
that in the years to come these women
that stood up it's all fiction they were
made up I don't know these women it's
not my thing to do what they say you
know I don't do that and you know I
don't grab them on the you know as they
say on the arm and once that he grabbed
me on the arm and she's a porn star now
you know this one that would came out
recently he grabbed me and he grabbed me
on the arm oh I'm sure she's never been
grabbed before and they make it so it is
it's all lies
all lies it was made imagine this
defense in any other situation Donald
did you punch Joey on the playground
Joey gets punched all the time Pat did
you steal the car other people steal
cars this car has even been stolen
before if this defense was written for
Alec Baldwin for his trump impersonation
on Saturday Night Live we'd be saying no
it's too obvious it's not believable but
it is actually Donald Trump's defense
and Donald Trump just needs to take a
lesson here from Hillary Clinton and
just ignore some of the allegations
coming out against him that's what she's
doing with the WikiLeaks stuff and you
know he goes against the media for being
so corrupt will stop prolonging the
story and the coverage will go away I
was interested to see what the
trumpeters would say in response to this
story and it was basically what I
expected on a lot of Trump trumpeters on
Facebook saying Oh Trump's really
telling it like it is porn stars are
probably grabbed all the time Trump is
spot-on anyone who doesn't like what
Trump said about Jessica Drake is
probably just overbearingly politically
correct or whatever it does not matter
what Trump does it doesn't matter what
the allegations are there is this base
that is just going to stick with him but
as I will tell you later on in the show
there is one very important group of
trumps base that is moving away from him
and it is making a big difference that's
later on I'm on Twitter at D Pakman send
me your thoughts about any of these
stories I've talked about how people of
all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
/ David support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join Zipcar com / David